what's up guys this is prestige and you
might notice this is a quite change of
scenery from the past episode
well i kind of forgot that my mic was on
mute the entire recording of that
episode so
to sum it up
i
made i got some old got some killed some
mobs and i got
i made a snow portal and activated it
with a mysterious twilight clock which
is nine clocks in a crafting interface
and i came here and this is a workshop
and these guys can help me this is the
this is the ice icy like dimension type
thing and yeah
so if you're and if you're doing this
and you you're like what's going on oh
no
uh this is the divine rpg mod and
this is my survival playthrough
now
the mobs oh hello
actually i'm going to
check chocolate log
eggnog
xmas lights
ice pain
that's it so the only weapon this guy
would give me is ice pain
which isn't bad but
okay the mobs what is this how can i get
this
let's see
coal stone
i wonder if that gives me any coal
and workshop lamp
okay
we'll take these resources
and so i'll go to the portal since
i don't know can you turn this into coal
oh well whatever
let's see the way i came out was
somewhere over here what is that that is
a frost archer who's supposed to shoot
at some
pretty fast speeds
okay okay back up oh gosh
what are you
oh oh oh nope
oh crap
you
yeah the mobs are kind of powerful
so
dang out of an iron sword
uh let's make myself a diamond sword
seriously bro
might as well be good
so diamonds back in there and let's go
now you'll see i made my
portal
in this room because i'm going to turn
this into a portal room so this this the
netherrack will be gone
actually even get okay i didn't get our
achievement oh well i should've rushed
some tnt since
last
those noises again last episode i'm like
what is this and i realized that is a oh
i searched online that's a dungeon
and to get that into that i need
explosives so
yeah you give me some explosives you see
i'm wearing full iron armor and i get
three armor ratings because there's so
much better armor in this
okay tunneled up here
so my goal is to get
ah
to get my stuff and oh gosh go away
and bail back in
oh we got lots of archers
okay i think my stuff is over there
yeah yeah yeah it is
okay oh crap
crap the glass side is still there
so we're gonna need some way of
all right i'm sorry we're gonna need
some way of getting around him
um
just trying to think
dang it dang it dang it dang it again
he hit some goods i want to get my real
my armor back that's what i'm really
hoping for
uh
let's not take anything in there unless
we like freaking know we're gonna use it
i'm going to
make
you make you no i'm not going to make
you
throw the rest of my dumbs in there
me you
and
we're gonna see how much damage we can
do let's get bring those with me
oh my gosh
uh hopefully even though the glass light
is fast moving we can take him out with
the shurikens
go
you want to teleport
there we go
uh okay oh there okay okay hopefully we
don't lose my stuff no
i do not want to lose you know what
music
it's on zero percent
that is a lie it is not on zero percent
oh my gosh
so i want to get into the dungeon
because i want to show you guys that
stuff except i'm not even sure if i'll
be able to
kill the things in the dungeon if i'm
getting pwned by this glass side
see there's the glass side
oh god oh
really
oh my gosh
come on
come on now teleport there we go
oh my gosh
i'm just gonna make a mad dash
since i'm probably one hit
tighter armor
so don't waste more armor
those things blew me up in freaking two
shots okay screw you guys
screw you guys
there's the glass side
okay
um okay screw you okay screw this oh my
gosh
where's my stuff
where's my hole
there it is
ow
no no no
no no no no
okay we managed to get back most of the
stuff
oh my gosh
okay let's see
okay i didn't get my helmet but that's
sorry that's okay
oh
that was some stressful stuff guys
i'm going to go back to get explosives
anyways so
still haven't seen any oars
yes i got my blood gems so i didn't even
notice
okay
there's a light source down here
okay lava spawns in this dimension
all right well we're gonna escape
oh okay
that's a dungeon
looks like a separate engine from the
one i found over here
hopefully because it means more drops
how
well looks like i lost my chicken
crossed much little travels losing
chickens
i didn't want leaves
workshop lamp um
not chaby
all right well okay let's okay we're
like low on the iron reserves
put you guys in there
frosted wood sounds like frosted flakes
uh shurikens
two
bones lots of bones
i need some food
she doesn't have any i guess i i lost
yeah probably lost a lot of it
okay let's eat that for now
and
okay let's throw the twilight clock in
there
and just other valuables
don't have any errors using the bow
egg is not a valuable
and i'll throw you in there too
all right well we need explosives i keep
forgetting that
let's take two
let's take the entire stack
and steal for activating it let's go
geronimo should really have ranged
weapon
a ranged weapon would be very beneficial
in this
let's go kill us some maps
since uh the traders
come on let's go
the traders trade snowflakes like with
snowflakes and stuff
so that means
and like you can only get snowflakes
from
this
like there are chests in here i know
that's the only way to get snowflakes
you have to break those someone's dying
down there
okay uh let's
let's set up the tnt right there
hearing a lot of really ominous noises
okay we got a rollum
so inside here it's a dungeon so there
will be spawners
i really ought to have a ranged weapon
i'll do my best to just smack him up
where are you going
yeah let's just do that to you
what
ah
you know what if i get my stuff back i'm
just gonna stay away from my skull for a
while
great
great that's just freaking perfect
that is absolutely positively perfect
okay at least a lot of my stuff
stuff's landed above
and he can't get to me i know he can hit
me when i'm right there but
hey
go away no one likes you
i'm just losing all of my stuff wait we
still got some other stuff
i didn't pick my foot in steel dang
go away
i wanted to try killing with tnt but i
don't have
flint and steel said loft
not
i'm gonna go get me some more flannel
steel and i'm going to blow him up i'm
also going to blow up the spawner
because vengeance shall be mine
ow
okay we don't want to get tp'd again
so
get some more flint steel
and let's kill these noobs okay you you
you get out here
you get out here get out here
dead that's what you are
you did
it's like i just wanna
get a bit of weeds
i only got one seed fail
hey my chickens back
because okay these cows
are the most glitch
tastic things i've ever seen
yes mates
i already killed your baby
because i'm cool like that
now let's get some explosives
let's see we're going to need one piece
of flint
and we're going to need one piece of
iron
and we're going to need to make this
teal
and we're going to go blow up some noobs
death
for all the people
so we're going to blow up this stupid
two people
roll
okay now um um um it's this side
oh you got your little friendly okay
well
this blast should oh
oh my gosh
i thought i was pressing shift
what the heck
now i have no idea what to do let's
close that
i've successfully lost all of my real my
stuff
the
hijack man
you got anything that can you can
sell me that's good
um
not really no
yeah no
let's go assess the damage of my goods
being gone
oh
this is annoying as heck
so this isn't even me doing anything
this is me just dying repeatedly
okay we got
dirt and a dot okay you stay back
oh another one spawned
that's nice
hey we did one damage yes
i would say i'd get a bucket of lava but
that would
kill
everything
now i have an idea
we have 30 use of
we have 30 uses with this pick let's not
put them to waste
all right so
actually i know what we're gonna we're
gonna go for the diamond pick
and that is
that's one two three down
one two three down so
oh
through the wall
what is that noise
if you guys think you can't see i can't
see either so
don't be complaining
oh do you know what these noises
oh
my gosh
freaking heck man
i had the most amazing master plan too
that was so good
oh my gosh great great now he's by all
of my stuff
is there two of them down there
great this is this is perfect
this is uh why is this so good
dude why did you spawn there okay now he
can walk up this is perfect
why didn't i pick up my sword
i could essentially kill him that way
okay um
i don't like you
so we're gonna do that
if i could somehow trap these guys
they can jump up and hit me though
no i don't want to do that
i don't want to do that
come over here a bit
come on
come on you little wanker
it's a british thing to say
i'm not british so
as most of you could probably tell
come on stop being bad
no that doesn't help
come on a little more
uh
this is great
oh screw you guys
just just you guys just suck don't you
let's see if i go here while you're
killed
ah screw this
take 200 hits
for me to kill these people
and more of them can just okay yep screw
this
all right let's see what stuff do i have
in here 15 hours of my real life
there we go what the get out of my house
man okay you're just whatever screw you
is that another one of you
what are you doing
is he seriously opening my door
oh my gosh well
that sticks right yeah i do
well looks like we're restarting guys
oh my gosh
wow that sucks
sucks bad
okay well
you're living you learn right
enchanted books do we got why do we only
have weird two smite three and
oh
my one just what i want
uh everything i'll probably get pissed
off attack you okay well this is
officially terrible
in my book at least
really
get out
i don't want you here
no oh my gosh go away
well
two corrupted stones i think they need
three cryptid stones
for a pick
any other tools so iron i couldn't
handle that
so
let's make a diamond shovel
and i have no sticks
yeah all the sticks
well
time shovel
snacks
five dimes 10 iron i am freaking set bro
oh gosh i'm annoyed
i'm so annoyed so super annoyed another
sword had sharp at a flame aspect so
that when i beat mobs
i would get
like when i killed cow or pig i would
get their stuff cooked
sadness
oh really we have a cyclops
yeah maybe the cyclops isn't i don't
think the cyclops is pissed off at me
let's try oh okay okay
yeah the fire aspect is really an
awesome
book that i had
give me some diamonds
let's go
oh we got the other one pissed off yeah
diamond
you stuck there too nope there you go
we're gonna get a critical i don't know
i managed to get a lot of hits off that
was good
okay uh that's some diamonds but we
wanna
crap there are two of them
i know what i must do
run
oh they can't pass through
awesome
we got another three diamonds so that
was the pick we just made
let me make some arrows
i flip i don't think i have any feathers
oh well how long have we been recording
oh my gosh this has been a long episode
all right guys i think we're going to
end the video here oh it's going gonna
be like oh we're gonna do all the
awesome ice cuff stuff and it ended up
being me getting mauled hundreds of
times
like how many times i oh my gosh
one two three four five six
one two three four five six seven seven
times
e buddy
i'm not so good
oh
screw ice car
there's a waste of gold on the clocks
well
hey let's see if i can go uh
see if i can go breed my cows again
since this will be a great source of
leather and
okay it gave one of you it
yeah there we go okay that's good
made in front of your child
why do you want to go in
what is it the guy in here
oh there you guys gone why are you still
here
go away
go away up nope go go
don't screw you all right guys i'm gonna
end the video here i hope you all
enjoyed i have a quite different look
and until next time peace out guys all
right well if you got this far i would
appreciate a like comment rate or if
you're new subscribe yeah thanks bye